this appointment is something that I
think every single human being on the
planet is feeling right now are you
feeling a level of sadness and anger and
frustration and fear that mix is
disappointment disappointment is a very
complicated emotion and there is a lot
that people are disappointed about right
now I think that we got to talk about
the disappoint that that you're feeling
and you got to give yourself permission
to feel it because if you don't own what
you're feeling and if you don't give
yourself the space to move through it
it's gonna eat you alive and it's gonna
cause you to act out for me when I get
disappointed I get sad and angry that's
what I feel I just saw somebody say I'm
disappointed that my husband can't be in
the delivery weight room with me because
of new protocols based on the
coronavirus and so I want you to write
down what are you disappointed by right
now what are you present to the other
thing I want you to do is now that
you're naming this disappointment not
having a hug for weeks not seeing my
boyfriend starting to feel depressed my
husband I'm disappointed that my surgery
was candled yes I miss 30a as well I
really do that graduation was canceled a
lot of things getting canceled I see
that and here's what I want you to
understand disappointment is a really
complicated emotion because it's a
combination of a bunch of things it's a
combination of hurt of anger of sadness
and here's the big one you ready loss
loss
you are literally grieving something
that you expected to happen here's
something that I find to be really
helpful it's very hard to see if you're
if you ever watched the Mel Robbins show
you're gonna you can go to Mel Robbins
calm slash stay connected and you will
be able to find
a link to what we call a word wheel and
I use this all the time to help me find
words that are helpful right here in the
center are the words that we typically
speak in I'm sad I'm happy I'm angry I'm
afraid I'm surprised and then when you
come out I'm happy you go and you get
into these deeper more complicated words
and on the outer edge are words like I'm
disappointed I am in adequate I'm
inferior I'm insignificant I'm helpless
I feel out of control
I feel perplexed and finding the exact
emotion that you're feeling is super
super super helpful because when you
identify that thing that you're feeling
and you allow yourself to feel it which
is the hardest thing in the world to do
I mean I just gave you an example live
of how hard it is to stand in discomfort
and that's what disappointment is it's
uncomfortable it's one of the hardest
feelings to stay in because it's a mix
of all these other things
finding your words using this word wheel
can really help you process it faster so
once you've named it and you felt it and
you stood in the discomfort now let's
give you a couple simple things to move
through it okay here we go
the number one thing that helps you with
disappointment once you name it once you
feel it once you honor it is reminding
yourself that better days are coming and
here's how you can do that I have found
it extraordinarily helpful to pick a day
out in the future and for me it's the
end of August I don't care what the
experts say right now I'm just picking
the end of August and I'm
picking a day where I am anchoring
myself out in the future saying better
days are coming I know that I can be
disappointed that all this stuff is
happening but better days are coming
pick a new date when the better days are
coming and here's a trick that has
helped me I want you to think about
something that you would love to do once
the pandemic is over once we have gotten
through this together once we can all go
outside once our doctors and nurses are
safe and sound and and all of this chaos
has left us behind where do you want to
go what is the thing you most look
forward to doing I'm going to share mine
then I want you to share yours okay so
the thing I am most looking forward to
doing is I am most looking forward to
going back home where I grew up to
Western Michigan and going out to the
state park at Lake Michigan and walking
across those sand dunes and walking
across the sand and going out into Lake
Michigan and taking a swim when I can do
that
I am now B this is behind me the
disappointment is behind me and I know
that I am in better days
there are talk to me that for some of
those people out there that are
experiencing a little bit of worry how
do we help them to see that there's an
opportunity in the midst of the
uncertainty you know if you're feeling
that right now I think the number one
thing is to just start asking yourself
better questions and really in my
opinion you got to create space right
now like I know you're anxious that so
many of us humans were so used to doing
let go go go hustling we've got that job
you're used to working at you're used to
like think about your whole your whole
lifestyles change now right you're
typically on the go you're typically
doing things so in my opinion right now
is the best time
for you to actually get rid of any
distractions and take the time to start
asking yourself what is your purpose
mm-hmm what is your purpose you know
what is the thing that deeply feels but
that your call to to step forward and
and actually start who do you want to
become so that you can actually manifest
the success that you wanted life the
love that you want in life the circle of
friends you want in your life
like really start re-evaluating yourself
at all new levels of my life all new
levels of what I've always wanted to
achieve it's always it's always
challenging me to step forward to become
a new version of gerard adams like the
version of gerard items that you're even
seeing right now on this live isn't the
gerard that i was a day ago and that's
because i'm constantly re-evaluating
what my values are what my vision is
where am I going what is my purpose what
is the purpose of my business what is
the purpose of leaders create leaders
you know and I just think it's a now's
an amazing time for everybody to start
thinking about what is your vision what
is vision coming out of this and the way
to do that is you got to cut out looking
at what everybody else is doing and you
got within you got to sit down and you
got to put pen to the paper you got to
sit down and you actually have to clear
your mind and meditate you know you have
to do these things that that um you know
it is not easy to do because you got to
like completely you know ask be with
yourself you got to get to know yourself
ya know it's the scariest thing I got
this from a guy named Matt George
he writes I've turned to you more than
once in this crisis my cousin is the
entrepreneur behind our tell salons in
downtown Vancouver she currently
operates three locations and was
hammered by kovat as all small business
owners have been ahead of the curve two
weeks ago she front loaded and online
blitz for $50.00 of services next month
for $35 now and sold twelve thousand
dollars in 24 hours it doesn't go very
far in downtown Vancouver but she is
fighting like hell thanks for all you do
this is amazing
a business owner who did not roll over
did not wait for somebody to tell her
what to do but instead said you know
what
I gotta get scrappy I'm gonna do
whatever I can I've got a customer base
they want to support me what can I do
boom let's roll out a deal will fulfill
it over the next six months or whatever
it is did it now who knows if that will
work I can't guarantee that all
businesses will still be standing after
all this shakes out but at least she's
fighting to live there's a lot of people
out there that want to like want to see
their dreams come true
and after this quarantine is over go you
know this is like reset the whole
world's reset so those dreamers out
there those thinkers out there those
problem solvers out there solve problems
dream up solutions
you know inspire the world right now is
that right now's the time for the
dreamers to dream up great freakin vibes
and songs and ideas and plays and
concepts and movies and sketches because
the world's gonna need it after this
quarantine whether it's 12 weeks
I'm sorry whether it's 12 days or 12
weeks what Trump says it's 15 days well
however my it's gonna be longer than
that you know it'll be longer than that
but whatever happen ever it whenever
it's done the world's needing in need of
the dreamers the world's in need of like
the thinkers the worlds in need of like
tomorrow's architects right now is your
time all the vibe setters trendsetters
right now is the time I was really
excited about going on a big book tour
which I have not done in a long time
like for my last book the timing was a
little bit abbreviated I did like I
think 12 cities but for this one
was gonna do 40 cities you know 40
cities and was so excited had all the
plane tickets but you know all the
hotels all the different venues and
bookstores and you kind of know you know
what happened right I mean the same
thing that happens like with so much
other disruption so at first I was like
man I'm really disappointed because I
you know I love having the chance to
talk to readers and listeners meet
people on the tour that's how I've kind
of built my community from the beginning
and I do very much enjoy that and I look
forward to being able to do that again
in the future so the tour is postponed
it's not cancelled like as soon as I can
do it safely and and like infrastructure
is rebuilt and all that I look forward
to doing it but what I've been at what I
was asking myself is okay this is the
message that I teach all the time you
know I teach all about you know
opportunities and spotting different
ideas you know how to make money in
different ways how to kind of reframe
situations you know different hacks and
schools and strategies and all this I
mean how do I apply that for myself
right and I have to be growing I have to
be evolving along the way and so it's
like what do i do at this time and I'm
still kind of figuring out but my goal
is essentially like you know virtual
book tour and you know the book comes
out April 7th I'm starting this series
of check-ins now I want to speak to
people wherever they are in their living
room you know unzoom calls to groups
co-working spaces that are now working
distantly or remotely or virtually so
I'm also trying to kind of you know
navigate the situation and figure out
okay you know what do I do if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there look look
into what's going on in the world have
said over and over